[Music]
we're on the Internet
Matthias asked this is for you Jimmy o
what do you think of men are on
Norwegian government's decision to pull
their investments out of ExxonMobil due
to ethical reasons of their involvement
in Equatorial Guinea
and please keep your answer as long as
you'd like
my mother's Italian and I take offense
to the word of Guinea all right Thank
You Jimmy done it seeing so much
information regarding terrorist activity
against the US and other countries do
you feel more or less secure living your
day-to-day life I feel actually more
more secure right now and and I live in
New York so I'm more worried about
getting hit by a but honestly I'm more
worried about hit getting hit by a
bicycle a delivery guy than a bomb
blowing yes I yeah what about you
getting hit by a bicycle delivery guy
also I the car that made it's always the
car I mean as much as I fear lots of
things and the environment and terrorism
but the car is the most obvious probably
culprit very particular making your life
second go from hey I have a great life
too Jerry Rubin in LA you know uh Jerry
Rubin Jerry Rubin soon you will be able
to radical guy yeah was hit by a car in
LA after becoming epic true Oh true
photo it did happen to someone uh okay
uh ok dis affirmative this is for you
Anna
this affirmative action break America's
promise of equal justice under law as
the economists said today wow the
economists said that today nope I want
to elaborate on that
nope not very affirmative I would agree
with that
you know I mean I think you know there's
a legacy from slavery that is if you
look at this if you I always do my thing
on affirmative actually look at the
statistics and and African Americans are
behind white Americans in so many areas
you can only come also people only want
to be with people that they're
comfortable around so unless we give
them incentives to think differently
about that and we live more and more now
in tribes and in small communities with
people just like us so if we don't do
things to urge us to be in contact with
one another we're just gonna continue
cycles ya know dad said I think you know
what well no we
the big idea of America is to form a
more perfect union and we'll know we've
succeeded when it's time to move from
affirmative action based on race to
affirmative action based on class
because that really is a larger issue
we're kind as well yeah we're moving too
uh but it's not just race I mean it's
it's it's GLBT rights it's it's women's
rights LGBT you see a key LBT and it
through everyone oh just a minute
it's all the same it's all the same very
self-centered of you well because I'm
gay to put yourself first I'll be nitron
you're gay
okay now you tell me what the shows why
did you wanna ask me uh no no I wouldn't
do that I'll see err little footsie
under the table yeah um but what I was
gonna say is you know when you look at
statistics like household wealth or
something I mean like black Americans
have like you know 11 cents on the
dollar but it's not some ridiculous yeah
it's statistic it's probably getting now
it's gonna come it's education it's nice
berries I mean you go on down the list
after brown people unfortunately
disproportionately are worse off than
white people I mean there's no question
about it you take a look at the
statistics we still have a long way to
go we do and and here's why it's because
even though affirmative action is on the
books even though thus in the process it
is enforced it's still not enforced from
a race-based standpoint there are still
a lot of people out there unfortunately
they don't like maybe just because of
the color of my skin and thus in the
process they have preconceived notions
about me and think that perhaps maybe I
can't speak proper English or perhaps
maybe I don't have the straw I should
tell you this is what the statistics say
and perhaps maybe I don't have a strong
work ethic as you do perhaps maybe I'm
driving down Beverly Hills and I'm in a
nice car and I'll get pulled over by
doing 23 miles in 225 miles just some
perhaps producers don't think I can
garner an audience the extent that a
white person can so I mean you know we
know that we still live with these
things you're not white
we know that without politically
incorrect sorry you will never have
asked that on your own show Jimmy um
when I say I I mean we
and you know no you meant me not you
probably me us the three of us
[Applause]
the three amigos but anyway as if you
look at just statistics and you see
african-americans behind in some of
these economic factors you you can
either say one of two things they're
behind because they're not smart enough
some people do say or because there is a
legacy legacy and you have to and unless
you want to say they're just not smart
enough the answer has to be there's a
legacy and that has to lead you to the
conclusion we still need affirmative up
roughly what I would say oh that's what
Anthony Robert if conservatives on the
Supreme Court overturned
you know affirmative action I mean
you're a conservative obviously after
Mary are you gonna be offended are you
gonna feel that conservatives have have
undercut you yeah they're oh yes okay
just check all right what does the anti
science crowd say scientists are wrong
about global warming an environment but
are happy to trust them with drugs space
exploration etc know what that no I
let's go back to Jimmy having
interviewed so many celebrities and
being a celebrity yourself
thank you what are some negative aspects
that come along with having Fame yeah
Jimmy what are some negative aspects for
you well I mean what do you do with all
the money that's it women throwing
themselves at you it gets tiring
well there are some negative aspects but
I'd look like an [ __ ] if I listed
them so only on the Internet well well
it is it's no fun when you're when you
come stumbling out of a bar and there's
a guy with a camera in your face asking
you what you think about some random
subject and then you're really too drunk
to not answer him I didn't know you
partied like that right really you come
stumbling out of a bar oh yes we have to
talk that's our show ladies gentlemen
I'm gonna go talk with Jimmy Kimmel and
get some
Real Time with Bill Maher ask bill and
his guests are questions right after the
show at hbo.com